[Music]
several American towns claim to be the
birthplace of the Sunday Sundays first
appeared in the 1880s when the sale of
ice cream sodas was banned on Sundays
instead soda fountain operators poured
soda syrup on ice cream added toppings
and called this new treat to
sunde today ice cream Sunday's come
pre-made and Frozen in individual
servings there's no need to wait this
decadent dessert can be served up in an
instant at the Sunday factory production
starts with something called the white
base mix it's a pasteurized blend of
Fresh Cream milk and a variety of
sweeteners a worker adds a blend of
yellow coloring to the white base mix
and this takes it from bright white to
an
off-white
a generous helping of pure vanilla
extract lends a distinctive flavor and
adds extra color to the cream base after
a final stir the mix is ready for a
freezing process during which air will
be added to turn the mix into soft ice
cream it's time to cue the containers
two at a time individual size Sunday
cups move forward on the production
line they meet up with the ice cream
dispenser
it automatically pumps precise amounts
of the soft vanilla ice cream into the
[Music]
cups it fills the cups to the 3/4 Mark
leaving plenty of room for
toppings it's now time to prepare the
next layer of deliciousness the
chocolate fudge sauce a worker mixes
skim milk and sweeteners to a frothy
consistency
and then add several large bags of dark
Rich
cocoa the mixer paddle agitates the
ingredients to distribute the cocoa
evenly
[Music]
throughout the chocolate fudge is pumped
into a plastic tote to cool
overnight during cooling the sauce
thickens up
substantially it's now a rich chocolate
fudge syrup
velvety smooth the chocolate syrup flows
out of the tote and into a big
tank from there nozzles dispense the
chocolate fudge syrup onto the vanilla
ice cream in the
cups next a worker pours a liquid
topping blend into a high-speed mixer
system that beats it to a whipped
consistency nozzles deposit the whipped
topping onto the syrup covered ice cream
now it's time to add some chocolate
Crunch to the smooth sweet
sunde the system sprinkles semi
chocolate chunks onto the Whi
topping It's the Final
Touch these single serving chocolate
Sundays have been prepared almost
entirely by
machines a conveyor now sends them
through an icy blast of air for a quick
freeze
exiting the freezer the Frozen sundas
travel forward shielded by overhead
guards for food safety
reasons the Sunday's funnel into a
single file Lane this positions them to
receive
Lids the lids slide down a chot and land
on top of the ice cream sunday
cups rollers press the lids down on the
rims
a revolving apparatus deposits plastic
collars around the
lids moving forward the Machinery sorts
the sunde cups in rows of two this
allows a robot with suctioning arms to
pick up six at a time and pack them into
a cardboard
box the boxes travel Under and Over
packing tape to seal the tops and
bottoms
incredibly this Factory produces
1,440 ice cream sundae cups every 15
minutes and it's all thanks to the magic
of
mechanization this company also produces
tubs of flavored ice cream so there are
many mouthwatering choices to be made at
dessert
time it's a fruit known by many names
cactus pear cactus fruit and prickly
pear it grows on several species of
cacti which are native to parts of North
Central and South America some growers
in addition to selling the fruit produce
a puree which they sell as a flavoring
prickly pear martini anyone cactus pear
fruit is high in fiber and rich in
vitamins and
minerals it's sweet and delicious eaten
as is or as a natural flavoring in foods
and
beverages in The selenis Valley in
California the cactus pear Harvest
begins around late August and continues
through early April the fruit is ripe
when its skin begins turning red the
Harvesters wear thick leather gloves to
protect their hands from the thorns and
safety glasses to Shield their eyes from
loose Thorns that blow through the
air tractors haul the cactus paars to
the processing plant the fruit first
passes over brushes and into a vacuum
that removes loose dirt then through a
shower of chlorinated water which kills
off
bacteria the fruit enters a cold air
dryer for about 5 seconds then passes
through a hot air dryer for 20
seconds the fruit exits completely dry a
quality control team removes any with
bruises or other cosmetic
defects and transfers those Cactus pairs
to the puree
line the fruit that passes inp ction
falls into what's called a singulator a
machine that lines them up in single
file the singulator deposits each Cactus
pair into a cup on a computer-guided whe
and sort machine which classifies each
fruit by size then applies the Grower's
price code
sticker the fruit then travels on the
conveyor belt that leads to the padded
tub designated for its weight
classification a worker stationed at the
tub packs the cactus Pairs and into a
lined shipping
box another worker removes any less than
perfect fruit that managed to slip
through the previous checks those also
go to the puree
[Music]
line on the puree line the dumper drops
the cactus pairs onto a conveyor belt
system which transports them to the
crusher the the machine crushes the
fruit separating the skins and flesh
mashing the flesh into puree and
extracting the sweet magenta color
juice from The Crusher the Pressed skins
drop onto the vibrating Shaker while the
puree and Juice flow through it into a
tank
below the Shaker separates any puree
still caught in the
skins
the Skins drop into a bin and are hauled
off to be used as compost or sold as
animal
[Music]
feed once the tank is filled to capacity
with about 400 lb of
puree a pump transfers it to a large
Hopper a worker releases puree from the
hopper to the finisher the finisher's
fine screens trap the seeds while
letting the puree pass through to a
holding tank below the seeds are sold to
businesses that press them into oil for
cosmetic and hair
products from the holding tank the dseed
puree passes through a second finisher
with even finer
filters then it flows into a tank for
pasteurization which kills off any
remaining
bacteria the puree is finally ready a
worker fills a drum which is double
lined with plastic
bags she draws four one cup samples from
each drum for quality control
[Music]
tracking once a drum contains 400 lb of
puray the worker zip ties each bag
separately closes the drum with a lid
safety seals the lid with a lock then
puts the drum in the
[Music]
freezer the cactus pear puree is sold
Frozen to the food and beverage industry
which uses it to flavor many products
from Ice Cream sorbet and gelato to
flavored water wine tequila and
[Music]
Brandy early versions of Pancakes were
thin like crepes by the 1780s American
Cooks were adding a leing agent for a
fluffier more filling pancake that's
when pancakes transitioned from side
dish to main course for the first meal
of the
day call them hot cakes griddle cakes
Flapjacks or pancakes there's nothing
like a heaping helping of them splashed
with syrup and with frozen pancakes
whipping some up for breakfast has never
been easier
pancake production starts off with the
leavening agent the baking powder they
combine salt whey and various flavorings
in a big blender to create a dry
ingredient
premix since these will be buttermilk
pancakes they add powdered buttermilk
for
flavor they pump liquid ingredients from
storage tanks into a huge blender
these include water in
eggs sweet cream liquefied sugar and
soybean oil they add the dry premix and
flour until the batter reaches the
desired
consistency an employee tests the
batter's viscosity by pouring some in a
device with a little gate he opens the
gate and measures the flow down a ramp
if it runs too thick or too thin it
won't produce pancakes that are the
desired diameter and
uniformity the pancake batter passes the
viscosity test they release the batter
from the holding tank and it flows into
a depositor
system the depositor has nine nozzles
each nozzle shoots an exact amount of
the pancake batter onto a hot moving
griddle because of the perfect viscosity
each deposit of batter radiates out to
form a neat round shape each one the
same size as the next about 10 cm in
diameter they run three depositors and
moving griddles simultaneously to
produce 750 pancakes a minute that's an
incredible 45,000 pancakes an
hour after several seconds on the
griddle one side is
cooked so automated stainless steel
spatulas flip the pancakes
over there are two sets of flippers
after flipping the first set repositions
and the second set flips the next row of
Pancakes it's mechanized
synchronization the flippers are spaced
apart exactly as the depositors are so
the pancakes arrive at the flippers in
the correct order to be picked up and
turned
over
[Music]
once flipped the pancakes continue along
the cooking conveyor and the other side
is
cooked it's a short ride for these
pancakes to be completely
[Music]
cooked from dollops of batter to
uniformly rounded and cooked pancakes
this process has taken just 90
seconds the pancakes somersault off the
cooking riddle and over a roller to land
on the next
conveyor this somersault exit has a
purpose it keeps the pancakes from
folding over so they land
[Music]
flat hot off the griddles the pancakes
cool down on the ride as all three
production lines merge and head into a
[Music]
freezer inside the freezer it's a very
frigid minus 28 C and the pancakes
freeze
fast now it's over to the packaging Line
This is where the uniformity of these
pancakes pays off their similar diameter
means they can be neatly packed in
groups of
[Music]
six Machinery seals two stacks of six
frozen pancakes in one
wrapping it has taken less than 5
minutes to prepare freeze and package
these pancakes at home prep time in the
microwave should be mere seconds just
add syrup and this story has a sweet
ending haggus is Scotland's national
dish made from minced lamb and beef
encased in beef intestine while
quintessentially Scottish his historians
believe haggus actually originated in
ancient Greece and eventually made its
way northward with the Romans to
Britain haggus is traditionally served
with mashed potatoes and turnips what
the Scots call neeps and tatties along
with a glass of Scotch whiskey to wash
it
down at the hagget factory the
production process begins with beef
fat they put it through a mechanical
Chopper and a guillotine blade slices it
up
[Music]
the chunks of fat go into a large cook
tank they fill the tank with water and
simmer the fat for 2 and 1/2
[Music]
hours then using a strainer they drain
the cooked fat and put it in a
tub then they empty the tub into a
minor next they chop up lamb
lungs haggus recipes sometimes also use
heart and
liver they simmer those in a cooked tank
as well for 2 and 1/2
hours using a strainer they drain and
remove the cooked chopped lungs and
transfer them to a
[Music]
tub they now take dried Shred onions and
rehydrate them with some stock from the
cooked
meat they pour the onion and stock mix
into the tub with the cooked
lungs then empty the whole thing into
the Menor to join the ground
[Music]
fat next two different grinds of oatmeal
medium and coarse to give the haggus
just the right right texture not too
stiff but not too loose the consistency
is key which is why the grind
proportions are a closely guarded
company
secret also a top secret the composition
of the spice blend they now add all the
company will divulge about this
seasoning is that it includes salt and
pepper the oatmeal and spice blend now
join the other ingredients in the
mincer and there you have it the
finished haggus mix ready to be stuffed
into
[Music]
casings in keeping with tradition the
company encases its haggus in beef
intestines after a thorough cleaning the
intestines are stored in salt before use
they soak in cold water overnight to
desalinate this also softens them up
until sufficiently pliable for the
stuffing process on the filling line
workers slip an intestine over What's
called the stuffing horn then with a
knee activate a lever that triggers the
machine to pump out a set amount of
haggus mix on this run they're preparing
the one lb
size they close the casing on either
side with a thick aluminum
staple now they spread the haggus out on
cooking trays and Pierce each casing to
let air Escape as the casing shrinks
during
cooking
the temperature inside the steam oven is
230° f the haggus cooks for 1 hour
during which the casing shrinks and
forms into a ball
shape once the haggus come out of the
oven and cool workers cut them
apart each haggus goes into a printed
plastic bag then into a vacuum
sealer the machine draws out 99 9.9% of
the air before sealing the
bag this vacuum packing process extends
a 7 to 10day shelf life to 4
weeks the packaged haggus now drop into
a tank of hot water the bags instantly
shrink and thicken by 25% making them
significantly more
durable haggus May date back to ancient
Greece but it certainly changed with the
times this company also made makes a 1
minute microwavable version a canipe
format and even vegetarian
haggus far beyond what Robert Burns
could ever have
[Music]
imagined